on est en attente d'approvisionnement
comme beaucoup réunion de crise dans
cette entreprise d'auxerre à l'ordre du
jour le coc vide 19 pour ne prendre
aucun risque cette société d'experts
comptables va proposer à ses salariés de
travailler à la maison
le matériel est déjà prêt donc là on a
un stock de matériel informatique prêt à
partir en agence pour accompagner les
collaborateurs en télétravail donc une
cinquantaine de postes pour lundi matin
pour les télétravailleurs
voilà les plus les plus hauts rangs la
priorité les salariés les plus fragiles
et ceux qui devront garder leur enfant
pour cette entreprise en plein pic
d'activité le télétravail est un bon
compromis est en très forte charge de
travail et nos collaborateurs sont aussi
intéressés à continuer travailler pour
satisfaire nos clients
donc la mesure la plus pertinente pour
nous c'est de continuer à assurer le
service et notre service peut être tout
à fait réaliser à distance aujourd'hui
mais travailler de chez soi ce n'est pas
possible pour tout le monde comme par
exemple dans cette boutique de prêt à
porter à partir de lundi véronique elle
sera en arrêt de travail pour s'occuper
de ses trois enfants d'un côté content
que je pourrais être avec mes enfants de
l'autre côté c'est bon je me retrouve à
rester à la maison alors que je les ai
pas demandé et que je suis quand même
une maman katie v c'est vrai que rester
à la maison a intrigué mais rien faire
c'est un peu compliqué comme véronique
deux autres salariés de l'entreprise
bénéficieront de vingt jours d'arrêt un
véritable casse tête pour le gérant qui
met tout en oeuvre pour maintenir
l'activité
alors je parle là on parle pas de
chômage partiel parce que on encore des
chiffres d'affaires qui vont nous
permettre de payer les gens mais je ne
sais pas ce qui se passera lundi devant
une station comme celle-là je n'ai pas
d'expérience j'ai rien s'est il n'y a
aucune visibilité pour nous pour les
entreprises qui ne peuvent pas recourir
au télétravail
l'inquiétude grandit au fil des jours
toutes espèrent que cette crise
sanitaire et économique sera de courte
durée pour éviter la catastrophe